[Musique]
déguisé en arbre et en végétaux une
centaine de manifestants effectué un die
in une simulation de mort pendant
plusieurs minutes
symbolisant la disparition de la forêt
pyrénéenne
ce dimanche matin se place du capitole à
toulouse
ils ont répondu à l'appel du collectif
touche pas à ma forêt pour dire non à
l'implantation de la scierie
industrielle géante du groupe italien
florian à lannemezan dans les hautes
pyrénées
avec cette action ils entendent ainsi
dénoncer le projet de prélèvement de
centaines de milliers de mètres cubes de
bois qui aurait un impact dévastateur
sur la biodiversité
c'est une action symbolique pour nous
qui représente l'abattage de la forêt
pyrénéenne florian donc le l'industrie
qui doit s'installer elle veut 50 mètres
cubes de bois d'oeuvre donc deux êtres
et si on regarde les pourcentages que
nous donne aux élèves sur les
disponibilités dans les forêts
pyrénéennes mais il faudrait couper
jusqu'à 500 mille mètres cubes de bois
par an les organisateurs demandent à
l'état et au conseil régional
d'occitanie l'arrêt du projet il s'agit
pour eux de rappeler que les écosystèmes
forestiers sont vite au regard de la
crise climatique de la préservation de
la biodiversité du stockage du carbone
mais il dénonce aussi une logique
économique qui pourrait bien être fatal
à de nombreux emplois locaux
les volumes qui vont être qu'ils vont
être abattus que florian on verra
ensuite
à l'international en asie en particulier
est ce ce bois d'oeuvre nous reviendra
sous forme de meubles autant dire
l'aberration déjà aussi écologique que
cela représente en plus aussi
effectivement de mettre à mal le tissu
économique local
pourtant selon la communauté de communes
de lannemezan ce projet est destiné à
relancer l'industrie de la sylviculture
dans les pyrénées mais de leur côté les
organisateurs qui ont obtenu un
moratoire sur le projet ne compte pas en
rester là il prépare différemment
nouvelles actions jusqu'à une par mois